Petty Roosevelt is best known for
securing America's natural wonders a
progressive Republican who believed in
the common man but there was a romantic
side to the Rough Rider that cbs's own
Mary Calvi is bringing to light calvia's
ventured to the Past before on her first
historical fiction book Dear George dear
Mary piecing together the relationship
between George Washington and Mary
Phillips who preserved documents her
latest novel paints a picture of a young
Theodore through real letters to and
from his first love who she believes
helped influence him in his early years
well we are following three big stories
when she's not delivering the news of
the day now to meetings between the
presidents of China and Russia WCBS
anchor Mary Calvi is seeking truths from
our past what is your fascination with
history where does that stem from you
know I think as journalists we want to
find the exclusive whether it be today
or 150 years ago and it drives me and
especially when it comes to a woman's
voice that needs to be heard her latest
subject love letters between Alice
Hathaway Lee I do love this one here
this is written by Alice and she starts
out my dearest teddykins and our Bull
Moose president every letter is written
to Teddy which is interesting because
Teddy Roosevelt didn't like to be called
Teddy although he clearly loved it from
her we met up at Theodore Roosevelt's
birthplace in New York City did your
view of Teddy Roosevelt change oh yes I
mean I had no idea this man was a
romantic he's writing things like I
worship you so that it seems desecration
to touch you no I can hardly let you a
moment out of my arms my purest Queen
Theodore Roosevelt was a passionate man
Calvin's new novel if a poem could live
and breathe is not just a fictional take
on the romance between Theodore
Roosevelt and his first wife but a
deduction on her influence on him
discovering these love letters that had
not been published before was really
what set the stage for the novel here
these were hiding in plain sight they
had been donated decades before and
really they have not had their time in
the Limelight she found them by
following the women in the family they
were in the family papers of Alice
Roosevelt Longworth their daughter
nobody thought to look at the women's
side side of the story previous
biographies had not been kind to Alice
Lee one biographer calls her
uncomplicated Bland incapable of
spiritual growth and says that if Alice
had stayed in Theodore Roosevelt's life
he may have committed suicide from sheer
boredom
Calvi thought otherwise she crashed the
gender barrier went into an all-male
Social Club at Harvard women did not do
these things she attended his boxing
matches I believe she was pushing him
further to understand women's rights
Calvi contends his speech at Harvard's
commencement in 1880 may have won her
over his first line I think there can be
no question that women should have equal
rights with men he was calling for women
to be lawyers he was saying that women
should keep their name upon marriage he
often talks too in this speech about
what happens after marriage they married
months later and he entered the New York
State Assembly they seemed blissfully
happy but then in February 1884 he would
receive her final letter I'm feeling
well tonight she said but I am very much
worried about your little mother her
fever is still very high and I'm afraid
it might be typhoid her suspicion was
correct Teddy Roosevelt arrives at the
house and his brother answers the door
and says your mother is dying and your
wife is dying too and so he rushes in
sees his mother before she takes her
last breath and rushes up to be with his
Alice and she dies in his arms his 22
year old wife died of kidney disease on
Valentine's Day she had given birth to
their daughter just two days before
Roosevelt buried his mother and wife
side by side at Greenwood Cemetery in
Brooklyn New York when Alice dies
Theodore Roosevelt very famously
writes a large x in his diary and writes
the light has gone out of my life
you can see down here is Alice Ed
O'Keefe is CEO of the Theodore Roosevelt
Presidential Library Foundation he was
demonstrably depressed he quit his job
in the New York State Assembly after
finishing his term and he went to the
Badlands of North Dakota yes to become a
Rancher and a cowboy and to live what he
would later call the strenuous life but
he went there to recover it shaped his
vision for this nation when he is
president of the United States He
preserves 230 million acres of land he
establishes five national forests he
establishes the first bird preserves at
the time remember this is a
revolutionary idea Roosevelt later
married his childhood sweetheart Edith
Carro who became a definitive first lady
she's the first to have a social
secretary and establishes that tradition
she oversees the entire renovation of
the White House house she's Theodore
Roosevelt's key advisor she will sit in
on cabinet meetings and be a part of
pretty much every major decision that he
makes correctly O'Keefe hopes history
will honor all of the women who
influenced this indelible figure sounds
like he was incredibly Lucky in finding
the right woman for the right time TR
perhaps ahead of his time sadly was
someone who really loved respected and
appreciated women's opinions and that
too has to be credited to to Alice and
to Edith for Calvi finding the new in
what's old is an art in and of itself so
you have a Teddy quote at the top of the
book
I have never done anything to deserve
such good fortune after losing her do
you think he ever regretted
loving it all this woman
that's such a question isn't it I don't
see Theodore Roosevelt has that
passionate romantic man in his letter
writing to other women you know after
Alice did he regret loving Alice I
believe not because I believe it took
him to the Pinnacle of love that any man
could experience and if he had not had
that it may have been a different
Theodore Roosevelt after Alice
and we all know that Theodore Roosevelt
after Alice but I have to say this was a
man who had a great deal of respect for
his mother her ideas his sisters their
ideas and naturally the women the wives
in his life
be right back
[Music]
so the rise of Theodore Roosevelt by the
great Edmund Morris is maybe my favorite
non-fiction book of all is it really oh
it's an incredible book
um
I'll have to add Mary's to you must for
the list here of Theodore Roosevelt
biography what a life well not just a
life I'm gonna go like full romantic
here that letter darling baby like that
language the light has gone out in my
life and putting the X in the diary
there's something about somebody who can
feel that deeply and express himself in
that way that you view everything else
you almost want to go back and review
everything else because it puts a
different level of emotion yeah no I I
tell you it opened up a whole different
side of this man I I haven't read a
biography on Teddy Roosevelt before
Roosevelt actually I know he hated the
word he hated Teddy but we hated teddy
bears
true politician he did he didn't mind
the uh the the the the name the nickname
when it came to getting the votes but I
I will say that you know it's so
wonderful that you are piecing together
someone his history and understanding
them in a renewed light it gives such
flavor and such understanding context
yeah totally